you
you
the heart has four muscular pumping
chambers the right atrium the left
atrium the right ventricle and the left
ventricle
the left ventricle pumps blood out
through a large artery called the aorta
to supply the body with the oxygen and
nutrients it needs in left-sided heart
failure the left ventricle is not able
to pump enough blood to the body the two
types of left-handed heart failure are
diastolic where the left ventricle can't
relax enough to fill with blood and more
commonly systolic where the left
ventricle can't contract strongly enough
to push blood to the body
in severe or end-stage heart failure the
heart is getting weaker and doesn't
respond to medication
four left-sided end-stage systolic heart
failure a doctor may recommend an
implantable left ventricular assist
device or LVAD to help the heart pump
enough blood to the body an LVAD is a
small mechanical pump implanted inside
the chest or abdomen that takes over the
job of the weak left ventricle blood
flows from the left ventricle through an
inflow tube to the pump the pump pushes
the blood through an outflow tube into
the aorta from here the blood travels
normally from the aorta to the rest of
the body a cable called a drive line
connects the LVAD pump inside the chest
to a control unit located on the outside
of the body the control unit is a small
computer that controls the functions of
the pump and alerts the patient if there
are any problems the pump and control
unit receive power through a cord
connected to a battery pack finally the
control unit and battery pack are held
in a light weight patient pack
an LVAD maybe a temporary treatment
until a heart transplant can be
performed or if the patient isn't able
to have a heart transplant an LVAD may
be used for destination therapy which is
long-term treatment